I want to have the best personality be
cocky funny tease and flirt with women
because I have like just basic
conversations I'm joined This Modern
flirting program I've gotten so many
numbers and the majority of the time
though they say they call me back they
don't okay what do you do for a living
right now I do delivery like doordash
and Uber you're 35 you drive for Uber
and doordash and you're buying some
pickup artists course on Modern flirting
and you're also overweight I can see in
your face no I'm working on that so like
are you seeing the problem here I guess
it's about like who I am as a person or
what I'm doing with my life well I want
you to get off the manual swamp crap and
get to the root of the problem the root
of the problem is you're like over 50
pounds overweight you're insignificant
and you're not interesting enough to get
high quality beautiful women in your
life you are a plugged in beta male my
friend Paul the master it should be Paul
the masturbator my man forget about the
game part turn off whatever that [__]
goof was that sold you that flirting
course work on the other stuff and read
my damn book holy smokes